former school groundskeeper dying of
cancer who won a landmark judgment
against agriculture giant Monsanto says
the lawsuit was never about the money
lee johnson alleges that his use of
Monsanto's weed killer roundup
contributed to his non-hodgkins lymphoma
last week a california journey jury
agreed and awarded johnson 289 million
dollars in compensatory and punitive
damages the jury also determined
Monsanto failed to warn consumers of
dangers associated with the products
Johnson used in an interview with CBS's
and a Warner Johnson says he hopes
labels change in the future why was the
label important the label is important
because as a pest controller and as
those guys out there and professional
doing this in a professional field of
applying herbicides it's a requirement
to understand your label and then look
at your label it's very serious there's
a whole chapter on reading the label how
to read it and what to look for so if
that was on the label people can make an
informed choice
Monsanto denies any link between the
active ingredient in roundup and cancer
the company plans to appeal the verdict
you can see more of anna's interview
with lee johnson this Monday on CBS this
morning